i really am a lesbian like i don't
really know what you guys want me to say
like i like to kiss girls
i don't know we brought together
seven lesbians i'm a lesbian i'm a
lesbian
i am a lesbian i'm a lesbian i am a
i'm a lesbian i am a lesbian
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize
this is odd men out
i'm going to listen to my gut listen to
my gaydar listen to my intuition
i don't know i'm like a little nervous
about how personal and raunchy the
questions might get
i am curious what everybody sign it
which i think is
a pretty lesbian question to have i want
to know their coming out story is it
good is it bad is it sad is it funny is
it crazy
[Music]
hi everyone okay who likes wieners
no i'm just joking i don't even like hot
dogs
i want none of it is everyone single
taken
single single i have a partner taken
insane
yes i am taken when did you guys
realize your attraction to women and how
did you feel
about it i didn't even answer the last
question
when you're a lesbian you're just always
in a relationship but also never in a
relationship at the same time i knew at
16.
my mom like saw my text between me and
my girlfriend
at the time so i like forcibly came out
of the closet i
also came out well i knew around 16. b2
is 16.
i'm sure like a lot of us have come out
multiple times
like a thousand it feels like you come
out every day honestly
coming out is a lifelong process i came
out like six months ago uh when i was
19.
i like read the essay compulsory
heterosexuality went oh my god well
welcome
i came on his bio when i was 15 and then
to myself when i was around 17
yeah and then it came out to my whole
family two years ago exactly so i
basically
realized it when i was a junior in high
school but i also thought i was bisexual
because
i never really questioned my attraction
to men and also because i'm indian
um which is like heavily stigmatized in
my community that both like i guess kind
of kept me in the closet for a long time
and i actually
just came out to my parents like two
weeks ago
congratulations that's amazing
yeah i love that compulsive
heterosexuality got brought up in round
one it's such an important topic to talk
about i don't know i'm the most
suspicious of myself like is my gaydar
broken
it kind of did look like an adita was
reading off of something she wrote out
but it could be just because she's
nervous
i'm gonna have to vote for rachel it's
just a hunch
i think i'm gonna focus i am gonna vote
for rachel just because she said only
one really big thing i'm probably gonna
vote out olive
and nandito had the questions and like
had her answer like
almost memorized i'm sorry olives but
i'm gonna vote for you the votes are in
for round one and we have a three-way
tie between rachel olive and anandita
each person will get 15 seconds to state
their case
rachel we'll start with you okay so i
came out
12 years ago now when i was 16 because i
started dating my first girlfriend the
only gay people in my high school were
me
my girlfriend and her ex-girlfriend
which i came to learn was a very lesbian
situation to have as i got older
so i started dating my girlfriend two
years ago we're
about to move in together hopefully in
the next few months in my free time
i volunteer for the trevor project i'm
like a huge advocate for lgbt
rights and everything i know i didn't
talk that much in the first round i know
that's why y'all voted for me
i did really hardcore struggle with
being a femme presenting person because
i do love femininity i love being a
feminine woman but i also struggled with
compulsory heterosexuality
so heavily that i kept it guarded for
myself for years and it's especially
hard because
as an indian woman i've been conditioned
my whole life to be
married to a man and have kids so i
think i'm gonna vote for rachel
i think i'm going to go for that i don't
know i still have a weird feeling about
nadine i think i'm going to vote for
rachel again
we have counted all the votes and there
is still a tie between
rachel and anandita each of you will get
10 seconds to state your case
okay well clearly i think you can be a
very feminine presenting woman and also
be lesbian at the same time
which i think i've also dealt a lot with
in the lesbian community from masculine
presenting lesbians
okay so i have a master's in sexuality
studies i study lesbian moms
i'm a queer um cultural competency
educator this is all my like queer
collection books
i can pull out my publications for you i
this is impossible rachel's story about
her girlfriend in high school is really
sticking to me so i think i'm going to
go with anandita again
i'm going to vote for rachel again but
if it's on adita i'm going to be mad
like and i kind of just said the same
thing again like she didn't bring up
anything new
i'm glad i'm safe i'm sorry rachel just
because you studied it doesn't mean that
you
are one and you could just know the
right things to say so i'm voting
for rachel again the votes are in and
the person eliminated in round one
is rachel
rachel honestly what's more
disappointing
is that it came down to the two most
feminine people on the call
that was crazy that was really really
really crazy
wait wait wait i'm gonna ask the first
question because i don't talk that much
in the last one
and i'm not getting voted out what's
your favorite lesbian movie
not my favorite one but did anyone watch
happiest season yeah
i was gonna say happy season also
because okay a little name drop i'm in a
band
and our song is in the movie it's in the
movie
yeah he's famous yeah i wish i
first of all just like watching a queer
holiday movie
chef's kiss that's why when i was
watching hunting a blind manor and i was
like
a fan lesbian and i was like oh my god
she dies
uh always spoiler i kind of have a
specific question
what are some of the negative
experiences that you've had with
other lesbians within the community oh
you're getting deep deep deep
no i'm trying to play the game kind of
coming out a little strong
with questions i don't know well i've
had a ton of negative experiences with
men
as well who don't believe me which
totally sucks having
men turn lesbianism into a performative
act for them
yep they're definitely like oh you're
too cute to be a lesbian like what does
that even mean
i can turn you straight you can't that's
why i'm here did anyone have any
negative experiences just like
overall like anything scary that
happened to you like i could start i had
a beer bottle thrown at me
jesus yeah that sounds like something
that's scary i post a lot on tik tok
lesbian take talk
i mean i'm coming out of my car to go
into my house and a bunch of teenage
boys are walking by me and i'm sitting
there and i'm like
oh no and they just start screaming my
name and i'm like oh
and then they start screaming thank you
and i'm like
wow i haven't had like a ton of it
because i came out like six months ago
and like corona is a thing so i haven't
gone anywhere in the last six months
and like did not look like this a year
ago like it was very much a quarantine
like gender performativity no longer a
thing so i look like this now
have you read the lesbian master doc i
have yeah
have you guys all read it i knew it was
a lesbian i didn't need to read a doc
yeah it's basically like a checklist
like do you do x do you do x
i can tell you i do everything i don't
have to read it i do everything
oh that was so scary i feel like i
didn't get to talk till the end because
i didn't want to interrupt anyone
isabel's music was in happiest season
and the director is a lesbian so it
makes
sense that they would look for other
lesbian artists
i still have that weird feeling about
anandida though kind of giving me
a mole vibe she just snapped being like
just because i'm femme doesn't mean i'm
a lesbian and i'm like i'm fan
i don't think that's what everyone was
voting her out for she's a baby lesbian
but i'm kind of suspicious of
mel olive i am gonna go for a desire
i fully trust isabelle and madeleine
they're canadians they wouldn't lie to
me
so i think i'm gonna have to vote desire
and we have another tie
between desire and anandita each person
will have 15 seconds to state their case
okay well i don't know what else i can
say to confuse you guys
for my fingernails i knew she was gonna
do that i'm just a feminine lesbian i'm
sorry guys i'm sorry i don't look like
what you think a lesbian should look
like but i'm
i just don't know what okay so clearly
she pointed out her nails i can't point
out my nails because my nails are long
but
long nails don't mean anything you just
gotta take your time just i really am a
lesbian like i don't really know what
you guys want me to say like i
i live with my significant other right
now my partner is non-binary
um i i like to kiss girls
i don't know what else to say because i
can't say nothing x
rated why do they keep voting for an nd
i'm gonna vote for desire
i have weird feelings about an adidas
but i think i'm gonna have to stick with
anandita
i sent in my anandika vote we have
counted all the votes and the person
eliminated this round
is anandika
beautiful i told you not super happy
about that
but i get it you know
i'm so mad at all of you i love you
i don't think it was an adita though
it's not me
i know but somebody was voting for her
over and over again so
i'm i'm a little questionable i kept
switching because like your answers were
really good
yeah so did i this is impossible i'm
gonna ask you a question
yeah go ahead what was the hardest part
about coming out yeah so it was like 90s
early 2000s for me there was
no representation on in tv movies
nothing i never saw myself anywhere
i think the hardest part was like coming
out to myself and just like
being terrified like so scared
feeling so alone so isolated it was like
how the hell am i going to move forward
now i feel very lucky that i grew up in
a time where like it's not it's not
perfect by any means but definitely in
comparison to
to you know decades before it's i have a
lot to work with and i knew that i was
queer
uh within high school around that time
but i never felt comfortable with a
label
then i went to university i met a lot of
really amazing queer people
i was like president of my residence's
pride collective and then i came world
shut down i came home and i was like
me and my on my own and my room was
forced to examine what queerness meant
to me and that's when i was like okay i
feel confident calling myself a lesbian
so it's been a very
newish journey but in the last year
there has been some really good
representation out there that i've been
fortunate enough to be like yes we love
to see it
my coming out in general was super super
bad because i got caught
doing something that i shouldn't um and
then once i graduated college i started
second guessing myself like is this
really right you know religious things
so then my hair started falling out
so that was really like a wake-up call
and then once i accepted
myself and my mom was like girl shut up
i love you
i was like oh then my hair started
growing back so now
i'm happy i'm latina and i was raised
catholic
and my mom like she was raised in the
way of like i need to get married to a
man and have children that was her life
like there was nothing else
so i knew coming out to her was the
thing it was a whole other thing when i
came out as non-binary
like that was a whole like well now i'm
letting you down even more like i'm not
even a girl
so it's like she's met my partner now
which is like
crazy to think of like that
happening like when my mom met my first
girlfriend i was just like oh my god
how's this gonna go
hearing everyone's stories is really
nice because there's a lot that even if
i didn't have the exact same experience
i can identify with it a lot because i
have those same feelings
i think i'm gonna vote for mel again i'm
gonna have to vote for madeline i think
i'm gonna go for desire
i have to choose mel simply to avoid a
tiebreaker i'm gonna vote for
desire again but if i love her so much
why am i voting first should i switch to
mel i'm gonna switch to mel
we have counted all the votes and the
person eliminated this round
is mel oh
my god this is really sad this means the
canadians betrayed me
do you want to continue the game give me
a thumbs up if you want to go to round
four
give me a thumbs down if you think you
caught them all and want to end the game
now
i don't know three two
one majority has voted and we will
end the game now
if the color turns green you all win if
it's red
the mole is still in the game and you
lost i
feel destroyed don't tell me with a good
time
in three two
oh my god now we're turning on each
other i don't like this
the game is over and the lesbians have
lost
that means that the straight woman will
be receiving a cash prize
and we're also going to be gifting her
the akintu experience
where she'll get to pick her favorite
basics from our new interactive apparel
brand
will the mole please raise your hand in
three
two one
it is true i'm in a band we are called
cave boy my band members
are women and they are queer and they
are my best friends and i am an ally and
i love them to death and they have
taught me so much
about their identity and i'm so sorry
can we all be friends
right off the bat i was like oh i trust
her to my camera like i trust her now i
look like
oh my gosh gaydar is not a thing people
can identify any way and also look
anyway
being out being proud in who i was
allowed me to continue to pursue
a life of authenticity i love being a
[Music]
lesbian
you